think big think big thinking really big
bigger go big think big dream big think
big because then you're gonna get big
then you're gonna go and achieve big
things that is the most important thing
you know we don't achieve big things by
accident so shoot for the top shoot for
the sky for the you know of for the
stars I come from a small city in
Florida in Central Florida and there's
not too many people in my city who sort
of spread out around the world night I
live around the world I travel around
the world nits it's really great it's a
lot of fun but I think as a kid I had a
lot of ideas that were really big and
both my parents had passions that they
never really followed my both my parents
love to play music dad play guitar my
mom loved to sing and play banjo my dad
did a little bit of theatrical acting
and but they never really followed their
dreams neither one of them you know and
I think that was one thing my mom always
wanted for me she always wanted me to
follow my dreams and to think big don't
you know don't just think of like you
know just a little problem you have at
school or just a little I mean you got
to take care of those things too but
it's thinking about the you know someone
like that all I long what he's thinking
about the whole world every time he
makes a decision you know and and if
people think if more people think that
way more big great things happen taking
risks for me has been a big part of my
journey
just thinking outside the box you know
doing the thing that everybody thinks
it's dangerous sometimes and just
knowing that you can do it knowing that
you'll get through it thinking big it's
something I say a lot of a lot of times
when I get warden arrows encourage my
family to think they think as big as you
can if we treat way beyond any default
you still gone so far short of your goal
you still have what would so high you
had some problems early on right you had
some time in prison we'll talk about
that later
what how did the rebound happen you what
this got a 10-year plan when I got out I
had a 10-year plan that I wrote when I
was in there on what I plan to
accomplish come when I come out you know
the goal is to stay out of trouble and
not come back into that environment so I
had to have a plan not the trouble you
know so ultimately that goal became of
course I started Konvict Muzik which was
supposed to be a concept that would
really have billet eight convicts coming
out and utilize the talent that they
have and they just sprung into this huge
entertainment enterprise so before
prison no music was in your head no
definitely not in a way of making money
from it it was more as a hobby yeah so
what happened but what was your big
break uh the big break actually was
getting locked up believe it or not
there explain that well fortunately for
me my concept was always thinking big
and before getting locked up my goal was
to be rich by any means necessary
so I robbed the bank that's one me
Leicestershire that's a risky but what
was scary was that that thought crossed
my mind a couple times before and
ultimately was it like okay how do I do
it
and get away with it and just made a lot
of bad decisions you know ended up
getting locked up which saved my life
once you get locked up for actually I
got locked up for a stolen car in a
concealed weapon how much time did you
do I ended up doing six and a half
months for that the judge was actually
lighter on me he started the potential
so out of the edge felt there was there
a break in the first solo artist to
simultaneously hold the number
number two spots on the Billboard Hot
100 that wouldn't guess you wouldn't
guess that for someone coming out of
prison absolutely not
you know what did it I think it was more
of the drive and constantly recording
constantly you know just working towards
that plan to one day work with Michael
Jackson and become the biggest you
didn't know him I didn't know but you
wanted to work with him that was the
time I was at the top of my goal I said
if I can shoot for the sky you know at
least so you set goals high absolutely I
think the most important thing about
growing a business successfully is
thinking ahead about where you're going
to be so I think about like the three
tips you have for scaling an
organization the first I think the most
important is to think big people think
about how do you manage how do you
motivate an organization and I think
about management you know basically the
science of administering a business or
leadership and my favorite definition of
leadership is the art of accomplishing
more than the science of management says
as possible when you have a big vision
when you're thinking really big
something that can change the world so
my favorite example connecting the world
which was Mark Zuckerberg vision for
Facebook that's the kind of thing that
excites people and motivates them that
gets them to follow you not just because
they work for you and they need to do
what you say well because they believe
in what you're trying to do and when
you're trying to really scale an
organization you need to go really
quickly and get people to accomplish
more than they thought was possible
and I think that comes from internal
motivation which really comes from a
vision that's big enough what is it
you're really after and is it after what
you are you after enough for yourself
are you are you limiting yourself based
on your current competencies a lot of
people do that they narrow their vision
or their ambition for tomorrow based on
what they can do today or who they are
today without realizing they can develop
their
Street their skills their competency
their knowledge or experience without
realizing they can become a better
person they can live into their highest
self they can live into the type of
person who could accomplish those goals
who could have those things so never
limit your ambitions based on your
current competencies never limit
yourself today based on your current
inadequacies because those can be
irrelevant
tomorrow the main thing is to have aim
in life to have your own aim to have
your own ambitions not the ambition
somebody told you you should have or
someone told you you're supposed to be
after because that's how we all get on
sort of you know sometimes a corporate
treadmill or we get on those things
where we just start trying to live a
life that's not even our own because
we're just going with everybody but
ambition liberates that your individual
ambition who you want to become what you
want to do what you want to contribute
and the highest forms of all ambition
usually come down to your creative
expression your contribution and your
connection with others that creative
expression what is it you want to create
in this world and I mean get your hands
dirty doing you know not just create
some PowerPoint once in a while for some
corporate thing but something real and
meaningful that you consider art for
yourself whatever that is even if it is
a PowerPoint presentation right but to
do something that you find artistic and
meaningful that's our human drive for
creative expression then what about
contribution what's your ambition to
give and to serve greatly for others
what do you really want to give back or
give to others what is it
and what about connection you know the
ultimate ambition and aim to have I
think for a lot of people is their
relationships to operate and have a love
that knows no bounds I mean a love that
is extraordinaire it is amazing you
can't improve your relationship with
your family or your spouse or those that
you serve unless you have in some sense
about you that desire to love or give or
connect more so today
get clear what is it you want and is it
big enough for yourself not limiting
yourself based off your inadequacies
your competencies but based on what you
truly desire last challenge take
whatever that is that you come up with
and TEDx it take it by ten times what
would be ten times that in addition not
just because it's silly I know I know
it's kind of silly but to take that
ambition that you initially have which
is usually what we usually want is an
impulse based on who we are today I just
challenge people don't think bigger for
yourself because you are a mix you are
magnificent you are powerful beyond your
current understandings so break through
that another little challenge your brain
to think even bigger for yourself even
it's just Eva's activity to break the
bounds of your current beliefs and
behaviors you deserve something
extraordinary in your life but at first
you have to want it go big or go home
it's so easy to think that if you play
it safe if you do it a little simpler a
little smaller you won't scare yourself
you won't scare your friends or your
family you won't scare your investors
when you go ask them for money it's just
not true the world just doesn't work
like that
it's counterintuitive but you can't go
too big
you really can't the bigger you go the
more inspired you will be personally and
trust me you will need to be inspired to
get through the hard times that will hit
you the bigger you go the more of a
cause you can make it for the people who
you're going to need to attract hey come
with me we're going to do something and
make the world 5% better yeah you know
what I'll stay my current job we're
going to make the world ten times better
we're going to make the world a hundred
times better now you got me now it's
like I'll ask what I'm getting paid
three months after I start work right
that's the feeling that you need to be
able to create in people in order for
them to join you so go big or go home to
be an intrapreneur and also to be a
visionary person you have to actually be
very
very bold you have to be ready to take
calculated risk not just any risk you
have to take a calculated risk you have
to think big if you think small you
always have been small in life what do
you mean by think big well each one of
those letters means something special
the t is for talent which guy gives to
everybody and everybody has their own
unique set of talents develop those use
them and let those carry you where they
will the H is for honesty if you lead a
clean and honest life and you don't have
a bunch of skeletons in the closet it's
really hard for them to come up if you
don't put them in there and it really
uncomplicated your life quite
substantially the I is for insight which
comes from listening the people have
already gone where you're trying to go
you know a lot of the adults in your in
your life have been through the very
things that you're going through right
now and if you can talk to them and see
what lessons they learned maybe you
don't have to repeat the same thing now
maybe that will allow you to move much
further and faster than they did the N
is for nice be nice to people because
once they get over their suspicion of
why you're being I still be nice to you
and you can get so much more done when
you're being nice when they're being
nice and not get caught up in the
meanness and the selfishness that is
promoted by many segments of our society
the K is for knowledge which is the the
way that you make yourself more valuable
and no one else can do that for you you
have to actively participate in the
process of becoming knowledgeable and
the mechanism for doing that is the next
letter B books you know some people say
I don't like reading books besides that
I can learn anything I need to learn
from watching DVDs and videos but it's
like saying that you can develop your
muscles by watching somebody else with
weights you know it doesn't work that
way you have to exercise your brain if
you want it to work for you and reading
is a perfect way of doing that
the second eye is for in-depth learning
learning for the sake of knowledge and
understanding as opposed to just
learning some answers so that you can
put them down on a quiz that superficial
learning doesn't last very long and the
last letter G is for God which is such
an important part of each of us as
individuals and the fabric of our nation
and we make a grave error when we allow
the secular progressive movement to push
God out of our lives you know we
shouldn't try to force God on them but
by the same token we should not allow
them to remove God from our lives most
entrepreneurs are dreamers we dream big
we dream out at a box and we dream out
of the reality of our circumstances of a
lot of us come from the inner cities and
we want to be somebody but after you
have your dream and you have your vision
you have to open your eyes and see and
deal with the reality of what it's going
to take for you to achieve that dream
and now the real work begins
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know how do
you think big and also what did you take
from the clips which one did you like
the most why how is it going to impact
you leave it in the comments below and
I'll join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon